how has the response been from the
family to you running is this good is
this mixed I would say if they all voted
or I think there was 105 of us at the
cave
um over Fourth of July weekend
if they all had to vote I would I think
I think Biden would beat me
my family loves him okay
his family yes yes I have a lot of
people who support me in our family but
probably slightly more than our uh I
don't know I mean they're you know I
feel loved by my whole family right so I
don't feel like it's I think that you
know but is it fair to say that there's
some people in the family they're
institutionalists and yeah and there you
know there's five members of my family
that work for Biden in the
administration and everybody in my
family that's awkward